oh c'mon a lame-ass math and I must stir
it right stir it with some water and
then should I put water in this thing
high bit more get a nice to move it
around
hi I'm RIA and I'm curly in a Pascal he
showed me his favorite Salvatorian
recipe just speaking in Spanish but I
thought think they're gonna be fine if
we reverse today yes today we is gonna
teach me her favorite Japanese recipe
bit more cardi what kill9 yachts guru
questioning my sense so stay with us
your new home will discuss Cardini do
see the photos I became myself yes it's
so beautiful and so in are you ready yes
how do you say it let's do this in
Japanese come buddy mush all do you have
any favorite Japanese food all of it all
of it yeah I'm always like down I'm
always open to any sir so let's see if
this year favorite Japanese choice shown
you do do consume in my shop let's do it
let's do it
maybe I'll teach you 1 to 5 in Japanese
okay each so like eating each knee it's
like me some it's like some she's like
Shh go it's like go wow yeah heh go yeah
that's how Yoko melt a commercial
okoma it sounds like go mad which means
to eat for us I'm guess I'm ready to
commit so I'm gonna push this little
button right here it's like an old CD
player okay so then we'll do big high so
let's put Aquaman Sango three of these
okay I'm all for it
Wow so people are like I'm cooking in
Japanese heaven
that's one you're not only taking a
different language you're teaching
somebody who doesn't know how to cook at
home now on I must stir it right stir it
with some water and then should I put
water in this thing
high bit more get a nice oh you're gonna
wash it wash it okay okay let's go watch
this
yeah so the rice is washed now I've
never washed rice in my whole life I
feel like I've been living a lie homies
it me too
mm-hmm oil cook stir it better turn this
on and close this mmm
music water hi number three mmm sign oh
yeah I knew that one job close do you
thinking sorry and that's it guys thank
you for coming
until next time so you know Stephanie
knows that me me come on Iggy Oh
ham Bernie keep that was at the slices
yes I just get so mesmerized every time
you talked that I have like forget where
I am I was stuff to would be the meat
now dig on laughs the egg onion yes okay
is there a certain way that you need me
to cut these onions right Oh Martha
humbert humbert it's half amber all
right hello yeah hi okay is there a
trick for cutting onions that you don't
try use shop knife I just feel like I
want to close my eyes and just like oh
don't do that
yeah but that good mm-hmm
put this on here sorry I feel like we
need to marinate no matter when you go
yeah I like hot glue CMOS hum up camera
hammer it hit it this this guy I've
never used this in all of my existence
I've never used this this side or this
side what do what does this do to it
tenderizes it is it like a light chop or
is it
yes Oh God forgive me I did skip oil
spices this guy this guy hi yeah
do I need to dip it in here and put it
into this into it on here or just do it
on this
oh oh oh oh sure have you seen this guy
look at that beauty yeah sure Wow sure
- got it - got to go what is it cook
she'll sure oh yes do I want more
is this okay hi guys thick lip look at
this little salty baby over here alright
so we have seasoned the meat what's the
next step so Guinea put all molds goody
mas put all ma cross it love it develop
it fold it into something put it in the
back
horny como giko for the flower I was
like oh it'll be it'll be three
different things
mmm come on you go come on go panco okay
so we want all so far my bread
I was yeah Pam needs bread yeah oh it's
like powder well bread crumbs okay so
this will be a flower in this guy and I
just pour it on here and then and then
you said like tomorrow tomorrow which
sounds a lot like Tamagotchi yeah with
like little baby so I is that the egg
[Applause]
oh my god team I love to you yes that's
life that's why it's like egg shape Oh
actually go back Humbert Humbert oh boy
did it Campbell Campbell hi
come on go all Carly Nico Nico Nico
oh boy I cannot do this with one hand
yeah per mole mother mas these are great
chopsticks very nice long and sturdy
yeah it's cooking chopsticks Wow oh so
you wouldn't heat with these no it's too
long so if you saw somebody eating with
easy boy girl you've got it all twisted
when you go home what school mm-hmm put
it in mmm yeah
did I put too much flour I took too much
flour huh it's a total stick this little
meats been a bad bet hi absolutely come
on go
and I've dip it in the egg hi that time
my god this is so much yeah
come on go that means then yeah yeah
it's kind of show boys your mum been
knock called on Watsky mas I'm so proud
of myself right now
so Guinea what do I give up I give up
I'm pointing I'm putting the egg on here
no so then sew sew sew sew them all oh
I'm cooking we're gonna put it we're
gonna cook it on this we're gonna we're
gonna put it on the pan we'll put on the
stove Sugino step foot we're gonna fry
it turn this on or should I put the oil
first Oh a disciple okay am I putting
the whole thing in
maybe timber does that means that we're
putting in a lot of love which is the
Latino secret recipe good food
yes do you remember we did a mall
yeah so with it what's you I I that
means luck
yeah i i i okay I've never even seen
these I feel like I've been living in
the dark ages you put this for the oil
whoa
so it should be it like 340 that's the
usual temperature hi good to know
I would never know that without that Big
Bang good oh I'll give us do I use these
now whenever I do this I do this is far
and this is how I do it
just place the dinner oh it looks like
we're making a giant Rice Krispies Oh
except they spoke we how long should I
put me before color Jonathan so four
minutes what's go up sturdy Nadel and he
could if I flip it
in Japanese golden-brown called the kids
inator
potatoes call out Fox oh wow get Zinaida
mm-hmm I want to like name my child back
folks call a child yes if I say okay
okay and what should it be a little
could you go cook it is at 110 down he
could touch them Wow that's a good
future here
yes little rice cooker
that means she's ready do I need to do
anything with her she game guys over you
heard it once it's be fun yes yes you
did
look every day one pork chop at a time
Kaleo you'll get thick this whole thing
yeah okay look at that little nugget
right there I made you I made you so you
know step it next step I stopped blowing
okay mas joining you turn this guy on
to where oh we didn't learn past 6:00 oh
this little guy on this thing hi hey
meesa meesa onion i'm miso soup now
means it water mmm
water hi young burn no cheap one poor
mother mother I call a all put i bunion
a mouse or a tunnel or me the Walker she
must when it sets a boil
okay bath she hummed actually yes yeah
okay
this is bonito soup stock high which
means pretty soup stuff cuz I do sound
annoyed you teaspoon a little bit somber
my dad come on Iggy I named okay show
you show me show you the onions
show you show you sources hi Wow
the good stuff right here asaji it's it
on even noisy one teaspoon all sad Jeep
also cheap
oh we gotta go baby that looks big salsa
salsa ichi ichi one yeah I'll just put
it all away humble humble
I know humble high-class not so good is
so good felt hot though so though the
ball yeah wait is this salt or sugar I
don't know why I'm smelling sugar I
don't know if sugar has a smile combo
half of this I didn't even ask if I
should put it in here I just was looking
up and meeting hi
what is this sweet and savory rice
cooking wine okay combo
it's
[Music]
when else you use this we use this a lot
for Japanese good game this is like
essential
it's like flavoring it's a little bit
sweet Wow okay so cool masa masa masa
masa so is this what used to cook into
stir it like on a pan instead of like
the wooden spoon we use chopsticks for
everything yeah cooking like when you're
frying pork chop like we use chopsticks
more sense that's why they long race
that you can do that come on pick a tile
size em us razzuma aggressively or like
tender really believe family yeah pork
pork
mmm yeah kitty mouse and just slice it
this way uh-huh
pick it it you name us put it in here hi
Sookie come on okay so you said next egg
oh my god you know muss around oh it's
awesome
this is bomb jaw stop
oh and me huh two minutes
yeah go home fold it go home go home oh
the race yes open Wow it's not that
there's no sweet rice hi Gohan okay so
I'm gonna use this scoop into this guy
yeah
do I want to water a little bit more is
that okay okay hi
so it should be like a little runny air
right good we'll put this in here how
does one scoop this in here just like
submittals idiot
hi excited are
that's beautiful
yes great you did great I'm going to get
mine okay we can compare this okay Wow
oh my god it's insane well yours already
looks so much better than mine this is
your first time ya know why - this is
your oh by the way do you know what's
this dishes
I don't its tonkatsu it's like fried
pork and this dish named cuts it off I
hope you like it I already know I'm
gonna like you how do you go wrong with
all of these ingredients
let's try mine okay you know what this
suppose okay like oh I'm so hungry so
excited I'm gonna get what you dropped
all the textures all the flavors are
there so you get the crunch on the
outside you get the tenderness of the
meat and the egg on the inside as well
it doesn't really taste like anything
that we would have and Salvadorian food
because of the different sauces that we
put in you will love this yeah should we
do mine laughs okay mine is definitely a
little um no here it looks great great
thank you must
yeah also we say that like you must
before you eat it you must like thanks
for the food I love that all right well
good luck yes is it doing well in your
mouth
mm-hmm they say don't look fancy you did
a great so I love you cuz I am such a
fan of Japanese culture and tradition
much like Central American culture we do
carry a lot of our traditions over so
this doesn't like something new that we
made up it's part of who we are as
humans so thank you so much I'm use the
word to me
[Applause]
all right but I'm taking this 100 yes
choo-choo-choo I'm so bad okay
[Music]